hallo mein name ist luca und genau vor
einer woche habe ich die erste folge von
diesem spiel hochgeladen dieses spiel
hier ist an turn das ist ein zweifel
zombie-spiel den letzten part davon
verliere ich euch mal hier
da könnt ihr euch den mal anschauen um
zu wissen wie wir an dieses quad unter
anderem gekommen sind allerdings ist
dieses quad leer und ich weiß nicht wie
wir das auffüllen außerdem haben wir
auch im inventar ein was ist das wir
haben den fakt rostock so stellt sich
das ganze auf jeden fall schon mal ein
bisschen leichter da wir haben unten
links immer noch die ganzen anzeigen
wenn das geld gleich mehr als genau
jetzt dann können wir nicht mehr
sprinten kann man da hinten sind häuser
das hier ist quasi so die komplette map
wir sind gerade hier wir waren in den
letzten part hier glaube ich und ich
hoffe jetzt einfach mal dass wir hier
gleich in den brötchen finden oder
zumindest irgendwie was zum essen oder
zum gesundheit aufladen oder irgendein
fahrzeug damit wir mal ein bisschen
vorankommen ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht wie das bei solchen zweifel zombie
spielen so ist ich hab' daisy mal eine
zeitlang gezockt was also wenn man
stirbt muss man wieder 1000 jahre laufen
allerdings ist die map hier natürlich
nicht so groß wie bei daisy ich hätte
jetzt gerade ehrlich gesagt viel lieber
einfach hinten auto in diesem spiel als
dass ich überhaupt mehr leben habe
das ist mir irgendwie viel wichtiger
dass hier ist gegen die sonne art war
schrauben da muss ich aber klar
geld das wir noch mehr geld geben und
ich habe keine feinde mehr
das hier sind beide way immer noch wir
also
wir sehen immer noch recht komisch
bizarr mir den sophie laufer rücken die
seien deshalb wegen jetzt komplett gut
ich habe relativ viel was ist denn das
grüne eigentlich für eine anzeige ich
kann dir alles mögliche irgendwie
fressen also mit dem hungern
ich bin 22 prozent gerade ich konnte mir
die kommentare vom ersten video noch
nicht möglich sein echte rocker des
spielers zu spielen ich hab's einfach
direkt weiter gespielt was ist das jetzt
hier ich versuche jetzt einfach mal
diesen zombie da wo mein gott stier
es war ein richtig spannender kampf ich
weiß da vorne sich auch schon das
nächste auto wo wir uns eigentlich
gleich mal hinbegeben können damit will
man bisschen fahren können hier ich
versuche es einfach mal den zombie dann
nicht aufmerksam zu machen sondern wie
kommen die so gar nicht irgendwie
oh mein gott ich hab nur noch 18 leben
lasst mich berühren blöden zombies
das ist doch nicht wahr dass luca einmal
zombie survival games spielen verpisst
euch doch räume ich will einfach nur das
auto und danach wenig gehen ich will
euch an ich da recht es noch ein auto
ich will euch ja echt nicht wehtun oder
so und das sind meine hand ist auch
gerade kein bogen okay da hinten ist ein
zombie
ich hoffe einfach der sieht mich nicht
ich probiere jetzt einfach mal mir
dieses auto zu nehmen und erst mal nur
rückwärts zu fahren damit ich überhaupt
das verschafft auskommen die wir merken
ich gar nicht ich forsche töne bei die
ladenstraße oder was ist wenn durch den
ton
durch ist eine absperrung aber das ist
mir egal mein gott du warum und das hat
super geklappt mit dem tor west vorne
ist wohl irgendwie militärbasis und ich
werde gerade die schon von den ersten
typen da verfolgt aber jetzt ist ab werk
des blödes hat die haben alle kein
orange smog nicht damit kann ich jetzt
auch granate werfen
es verlässt denn jetzt ich versuche mal
von außen da ranzukommen so ein bisschen
abstand hier zu halten
das sieht aus den militärlagern ich
denke aber das geht gar nicht
also ich denke das ist dahin noch
komplett zugebaut deswegen muss ich hier
vornherein ich töte den hier vorne erst
mal mit messer damit sich quasi noch so
ein bisschen war okay und damit ich noch
ein bisschen munition für die gleich
drinnen habe gibt mir doch irgendwas was
ich will keine militär willst ich will
einfach ein paar pfeile haben ich habe
jetzt mal ein bisschen sachen von mir
hier vorne einfach liegen lassen weil
ich die welt nicht brauche und ich
versuche jetzt mal hier rein zu kommen
und versuche jetzt auch so passt wir
sind wieder vorne dem smog drin ich weiß
nicht was ich hier drin machen soll und
auch nicht warum ich hier drin bin aber
es egal ich bin luca ich hab kein plan
ist da oben einer halo um ein coty sind
der komplette rüstung sachen ich sehe
ich ganz schön cool aus schön wieder
runter klettern und jetzt einfach mal
schauen ob wir hier vorne noch ein paar
leute töten können einfach weiß mit dem
messer mit sind langweilig ist nämlich
jetzt mal die backform schnell vorne ab
lukas nach wollen dieses spiel macht
unheimlich spaß ich kann die rumlaufen
ich kann diese zombies shilton ist es
nicht so daisy mäßig dass man denkt okay
ich muss das jetzt so extra speziell
moderieren damit nicht doch einer drin
ich schmeiße jetzt mal einfach noch so
ein oranges mokiert vorne hin was der
bringt weiß ich noch immer nicht ich
habe mir auch gerade hier so ein mini
tarif gekrallt aus diesem lager hier
vorne und jetzt explodiert
mein gott mir kommt irgendwie viel zu
viele menschen von denen an
ach du heilige lukas ein leben ich habe
keine munition mehr
ich habe keine munition mehr was soll
ich jetzt machen ich kann ich mal
sprinten was passiert hier was machen
was ein tolles ende beim 23 dezember
haben wir so einen kleinen stern wir
haben eine neue kette für alien oder die
andere lady und wir haben ein geschenk
wenn euch diese folge gefallen hat und
ihr euch sagt 'mensch luca bitte spieler
norbert anton wir haben so viele tipps
für dich da lese ich mir jetzt auch mal
durch und dann zeigt sie mit einer
bewertung und klickt auf die werbung und
freut euch und trinkt wasser weil es
gesund